[موسيقى]
بدون مقدمات تضرب الهجمات الامنيين في
سيريلانكا اختارت منهم الاقليه المسيحيه
غير الحاكمه فجرت الكنائس بالمصلين في عيد
الفصح والفنادق فوق رؤوس السياح بعمليه
عنقوديه تبناها تنظيم الدوله و يستلزم
تنسيقها وتنفيذها في وقت واحد شغل اجهزه
مخابرات وقبل الكنائس اعتدى على المساجد
في بلد لا حول فيه للمسلمين ولا قوه
للمسيحيين الى العناوين
رئيس البيرو لا سبق ينتحر امام سلطه همت
باعتقاله
في السودان نعم للفول والطعميه ولا لدعم
السعوديه
المسماه يفضح الاصدقاء الذين يقصفون
طرابلس
هدد السعوديه بالفناء ففتحوا له باب
الكعبه
نقطه السياح تتكرر من فريق المنشار لجاسي
الامارات
روتانا تعاقب ال يسال ذكرها بالخطا اسمها
سوق في
استفتاء الكراتين و حزب النور و نانسي
عجرم
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في الهند قطع شاب اصبعه اثر نوبه
غضب بعدما اخطا بتصويته للحزب الحاكم في
الانتخابات
فماذا سيقطع من ابتلي بحاكم تصوت له الموت
انتظرت اوكرانيا مئات السنين قبل ان
يتراسها هذا الاسبوع ولو ديميريل ينجح
ممثل كوميدي فيما يت والى المهرجون على
حكم دول تعرفونها منذ عشرات السنين في
الارجنتين اكتشف العلماء مقبره
الديناصورات منقرضه تعود الى مائتين
وعشرين مليون سنه مع بقاء 10 حيوانات
بائده فيما اكتشف قبلها في بلد اخر جنرال
من قرض في حروب بائده ليجدد لعبه الدماء
في البيرو توفي الرئيس السابق الان غارسيا
بعدما فجر راسه برصاصه في منزله عندما
كانت السلطه على وشك اعتقاله بتهم فساد
وفي اماكن اخرى من العالم توجه كل يوم
رصاصات الى الرؤوس معارضين على وشك اتهام
زعماء الفساد بالفساد الفتاه الفنزويليه
بازدياد رغبت عينيها عند الحلاق هي لا
تريد ان ترى شعرها الجميل وهو يقصد يتبعه
بمائه دولار تقدمها لاسرتها التي تقارع
الفقر والجوع وليس بعيدا عن فنزويلا
تستقبل القمامه يوميا اطنان الاغذيه
المهدوره اهل العالم لقيام محترف رياضه
الكونغ فو بعرض مواهبه في الفن الصيني
القديم برش الماء من عينه عن طريق
استنشاقه من الامن ولا يذهل العالم بجريان
الدموع يوميا من عيون الاطفال في دول
الرعب العربي احتفلت ملكه بريطانيا
اليزابيت بعيد ميلاده الثالث والتسعين
لحضور قداس الفصح في قلعه وينتر لتبقى
اطول ملوك العالم جلوسه على العرش فيما
احتفل زعيم اخر هذا الاسبوع بتنصيبهم ملكا
على جمهوريه ام
[موسيقى]
فيما يشبه المعجزه كشفت الغمه عن السودان
و اتاه الفرج من حيث لا يحتسب خالد ال
خليفه وزير خارجيه البحرين يعلن من
الخرطوم عن دعم المنامه للسودان مملكه
البحرين ستقف مع السودان قلبا وقالبا نفس
الشعار الحريه مقابل الرز يعرض الان على
السودانيين الذين طردوا قافله اغاثه
اماراتيه بالخرطوم وهتفوا بالمجمل الفول
والطعميه بديلا عن دعم السعوديه
[موسيقى]
ردوا الينا ابناءنا من حرب اليمن
ستكون وفوقها كاتساف
[تصفيق]
يوافق الرئيس السيده كلام احد خبراء قناه
اربعه وعشرين ثلاثين فيجب على كل عربي رفض
وجود مقاتلين مستوردين على ارضه يجب على
كل عربي ان لايقبل اي مقاتل اجنبي يدخل
الى بلده
المقابل
ياتي ويقتل هنا بالذات علق احدهم لماذا
ياتي الاجنبي ليقتل اخيك في اليمن وليبيا
اذا كنت قادرا على المهمه كانت تخاطب
الليبيين الذين مازالوا يصدقون او عمل
يخاطب الليبيين ليس لا في سماء هم طيارون
مصريون واماراتيون و مرتزقه من جنسيات سته
والمسمار يعترف اذن الان المعارك على حده
في هذه النقطه
اه كذلك هناك ضربات جويه اه طريقه لاهداف
معاديه في هذه المنطقه في الجزائر من قال
ان الرئيس عبد العزيز بوتفليقه لم يدخل في
عهده خامسه يسال رئيس الحكومه الاسبق احمد
بن بيتور مع الاسف الشديد الى حد اننا في
الماده مائه واثنين ماشي من سبعه وثمانيه
يقولوا اليوم الى حد الان هنا في عهد خمسه
بدون المترشح
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده لا تمزح حتى مع حلفائها
ستعاقب هم اذا اشتروا النفط من ايران لكن
ليس على احد ان يقلق والسعوديه والامارات
تعهدتا بالتعويض يعني اللي بيقول دول
الخليج انه لولا انا ما بتبقى اسبوعين
ولولا انا باسبوع واحد ان تتعلموا فارسي
ولولا طيارات كلهم بيطلعوا بالسنه وما
بيعودوا ينزلوا على الارض ولولا ان اول
ولا نائب يطلع يقول ما نحنا متفقين تحت
الطاوله مع السعوديه والامارات انه احنا
حقيقه
انه هذا هذه التغطيه من السعوديه
والامارات هاي مصلحه من يعني بمجرد عرض
هذا الفيديو للسيد نصر الله نعلم نوعيه
الاتهامات التي ستطالب لكننا لا نملك
مفاتيح الكعبه ادى رئيس الوزراء العراقي
احد مؤسسي المجلس الاعلى للثوره الاسلاميه
في العراق
المنبثق عنه فيلق بدر ادى الصلاه في جوف
الكعبه المشرفه
خلال زيارته الى السعوديه كذلك فعل
القيادي في الحشد الشعبي سامي المسعودي
زعيم جماعه بعض الله ففتح له باب الكعبه
واستقبل استقبال الفاتحين وهو الذي قال
اذن اعدام نمر النمر في الرياض دماء الشيخ
نمر ستعجل بناء السعوديه التي شددت على
دماء الابرياء والفقراء بحسب وصفه كذلك
فتحت للمسعودي ابواب القصر الملكي وحظي
بلقاء الملك سلمه
اعترف فلسطينيان محسوب ان على محمد دحلان
ب عملهما لصالح المخابرات الاماراتيه
بعدما اعتقل هما الامن التركي في اسطنبول
بحسب شبكه ار تي وقال مصدر امني ان
تحقيقات تدور ايضا حول الاشتباه في دون
اتيه الصحه السعودي شيء اعلام القمار تحدث
عن الجاسوسين وكانهما قديس ان وجه صبوح
وقلب سموح وبعدين تج
نعم
نفس التنميه مع شبكه المنشار الدبلوماسي
ولم ينفع وهنا نستعرض صور السياح
السعوديين الذين قالت تقارير في وسائل
اعلام تركيه وقطريه انهم متهمون بقضيه
اختفاء شفتي وتظهر الصور على غير ما نسجه
انهم اتوا بطائره خاصه
اذ تظهر مسافرين عاديين في صاله مغادره في
مطار يكتب بالمسافرين وفي الصور التي نشرت
ايضا صوره واضحه لرجل داخل المطار وخلفه
زوجته وفي جعبتهم انشاء
دون ان ينتبه تبني المعتقلين واعطى ما اخذ
منحهم الجنسيه الاماراتيه
بتغريده ليليه بعد القبض عليهم اتحدث
الاعلام السعودي فجاه عن اختفاء الف وسته
سعوديين بتركيا اكثر من الف وسته السعودي
اه اختفى في تركيا ثلاثه احتمالات
اما هؤلاء معتقلون واما فارغون من
السعوديه واما جواسيس عدم نشر الرياض
اسمائهم وصورهم يعزز نظريه الجواسيس او
الكلام غير الدقيق وزير العدل السعودي
تقمص شخصيه وزير العدل السويدي فاعلن ان
ايقاف اي شخص دقيقه واحده بالخطا يعتبر
جريمه
الناشط السياسي الاماراتي الصاعد خلف
الحبتور معجب ب اسرائيل الى حد الاستئناف
اخليهم يستانسوا اسرائيل دوله متقدمه
علميا
اقتصاديا
الكترونيا ما في دوله
الاقتصاديه في الوقت الحاضر والامور
الثانيه انا اطلب اننا نحنا ننتظر الى مصر
والاردن
متعارضين معهم فيجب علينا نحنا انه ليش
نعمل سلام مذيع سعودي يمنح نفسه صلاحيات
سياديه سيتخطى ولاه امره ويعلن تركيا عدوا
لدودا للمملكه انا ارى ان تركيا عدو لدود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والادله
والبراهين كثير اليوم تركي عدو يجب ان
تتعامل معها على انها هذا الموضوع ونفسه
سبق ان تسبب بازمه انسانيه عاطفيه بين ال
لطيفه التونسيه
والحكومه السعوديه التي وضعت لطيفه من
العمر فيما تمنح غيرها اختام الرسول
مدربين ان العمره عن الحج زيارات المسجد
النبوي اللي صاير سبع سنوات لانه اللي صار
ولا اعرف فعلا اقسم بالله ازال السبب ومن
وراء هذا ومن وقتها وانا خايف حتى قدم
فيها
لكن لم افكر انا
لكن اه
انا
اروح المدينه او كذا
اذا كان عادل الكلباني وسيم يوسف و محمد
شحرور وعدنان ابراهيم بن زهره يظهرون على
التلفزيونات بصفه علماء ما الذي يمنع
طالبه الشريعه الاسلاميه من الظهور على
الروت انه عازفا على العود اللي عزف العود
من هو الاستاذ
الدوله تخصصات او تخصص الشريعه صاحب نظريه
تنميه وعشرين الف كتاب لم يمنع من الظهور
الاعلامي بل تعزز نفوذه في المملكه واعلن
عن غزو سعودي للفضاء
المملكه اليوم هي تصبح مستقبلها بنفسها هي
تصنع مستقبلها من خلال ابنائها من خلال
تصاعد ها من خلال غزوها لي الفضاء بما
انما لكن الارض اليوم لكن الفضاء
هذه الاقمار الصناعيه وهذه الصناعه خطا
اليسا بذكر اسم خاصه بدل اسم اخر في حفله
لم يمر دون حساب فاعلنت ملكه الاحساس عن
احساسها بالالم من حذف روتانا اغانيها عن
تطبيق انغامي
امير السلك والترفيه تركي الشيخ يسبقه
لسانه فيقول
المملكه والسعوديه بلد واحد بدل الامارات
والسعوديه المملكه السعوديه بعد انتشار
الفيديو كتفه تصرف تركي باريحيه فخرا من
خط اه بتغريده قبل ان يسخر الاخرون لكن
كيف سيعالج تركي ضروره ك احد مرافقي الشيخ
محمد بن زايد لدى وصوله الى الستاد في
الامارات لحضور مباراه رياضيه وتركي نفسه
يقابل الامراء في السعوديه
بكثير من الاستهتار
مسلسل الكابوتشينو متواصل وجديده او لعبور
للبشريه كذا عبر الامارات وليس عبر نهر
النيل ولابد ان يفتخر فيها كل اماراتي ان
في منطقه الاف اه في م لائحه كانت اول
عبور ل ل اه البشريه كل هذه الاكتشافات
اصبحت سهله امام الاكتشاف الزلزال المهدي
المنتظر
اماراتي وصفه محمد بن زايد محمد زايد محمد
بن زايد يعتبر المهدي المنتظر
هذا مش الكلام للصغار العقول الكبار
العقول لازم يكون عندك وزن
التفاسير ما هو المهدي المنتظر انها
الامارات وعليك ان لا تستغرب فبعد وزاره
السعاده وزاره لا مستحيل وربما يعلن قريبا
عن وزاره الدنيا حلوه
يعني هكذا هو الحال مع استفحال ازمه
الوقود في دمشق اما تعليقه وزير الاقتصاد
يشبه مقطعا من مسرحيه كاسك يا وطن
[موسيقى]
ان التيار المعادي لامتنا ان يمنعنا من
الوقوف بحزم الى جانب حركات التحرر في
العالم اجمع مهما بلغ ان دراج التيارات
المتضرره على الساحه العربيه
مراسله ميدانيه ومكتره عثر عليها تحت
سياره تسال الميكانيكي عن رايه بالازمه
يترقب ما ستفعله المراسله في ازمه المجاري
قد يتحمل السوريون على مضض ازمه البنزين
لكن كيف س يصبرون على غياب مامون رحمه عن
منبر الجامع الاموي وزاره الاوقاف اوقفت
عن الخطاب رحمه رحمه بالمصلين بحسب بوست
تداوله المغرب
ستفتقد منابر الشام مامونا رحل عنها وهو
في عز تسبيحه حتى ان الحكومه لم تتحمل
تسبيحه في دفاعه عنها في ازمه البنزين
نعتبر هذا الانتظار بمثابه رحله ترفيهيه
والامر الذي يدعوك الى الفرح والى والى
التفاؤل بالسرور والسعاده
انك تجد الناس على محطات الوقود
يضيفون بعضهم البعض الطعام والشراب
والحلوى ويقومون على خدمه بعضهم البعض
المحبه ازداد
[موسيقى]
احنا
[ضحك]
مبدئيا في عام الفين وثلاثين فخامته لكن
ابناء من عدلوا الدستور من النواب والضباط
سيعد لونه لاحقا المهم الان الصحه واتقاء
الانقلابات العسكريه
ومواصله مسيره الزهد في مصر ما فيش خلاص
في مصر اه ح يتم التداول السلطه
النهار ده فتره او على الاكثر
ايضا موجود
اراده الله
مش حيكون فيه يعني لن يكون هذا الامر وارد
في طريق الرئيس لن يخوض انتخابات
قادمه انا اقسمت من لان احنا ما نجتمع
تشوفوا
انا رجل
ولا دور ولا مصلحه غير بلد الرئيس السياسي
ادلى بصوته فى الاستفتاء الكرتوني الذي
جاءت نتائجه موافقه حتى القهقهه ثم مسح
اسمعه من اثار اغرب تعديل دستوري سياسه
العصا والجزره
تحولت الى سياسه السجن والكاراتيه لازم
تعدل على عده والا فالامن بالمرصاد
في الترغيب
الرساله اجريتم بل على رحلات عمره و
بالحنطور وعود بثلاثه او بوتوجاز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اه
تدفعوا الفوري حقها واربح عبد ال وفتح
كراتين الدستور
ما بعد الكرتون ليس كما قبل ها والرقص
والغوطه لم تعد للعرب بل صارت للعرض
السياسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي احدى نواحي الاستفتاء سجلت ظاهره
صوتيه غريبه الجمهوريه شاهد يتبقى لنا
يتبقى لنا معلومات
يتبقى لنا
يتبقى
يتبقى الايام
المنوفيه شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك الكريم
سالنا متخصصا في علم النفس الاجتماعي عن
حاله هذا الصراخ الموضوع فقال اما اخذ
كرتونتين فارتفع الادرينالين واما لم ياخذ
بعد ويعبروا عن استيائه بالصراخ الغريب ان
هناك مقدم برامج يتحدث بنفس الطريقه
وحده وقف في وجه الريح النائب احمد
الطنطاوي لا يحب السيسي اليس حرا مثل كل
هؤلاء الذين توزعوا على السجون والمنافي
انا محترم حق كلنا في حب السيد الرئيس
وافق فيه واربع الاداء لكن انا شخصيا لا
احب الرئيس ولا افق في ادائه عنه ثم في
اليوم الثاني للاستفتاء ظهر باطلاله مريحه
من امام النيه مشهد بدا توزيع التهمه
اصوات اه
اصوات احمد بدوي شاب امور لم يتكلم مع احد
برفع منفرده اللافته اعتراضيه كتب عليها
لا للتعديلات الدستوريه
ضغط عليه الامن اطار الى جهه مجهوله
اعضاء حزب النور ومن باب طاعه ولي الامر
على شن راج الودي راجل اطلقوا اللحى ونعم
للدستور قالوا نعم اه اه
وكانوا نكهه الاستفتاء هو نانسي عجرم
[موسيقى]
عم بيخبرونا الشباب هلا انه تم فرض حاله
الطوارئ في مصر ليسوا بالاساس ما في حاله
الطوارئ مفاجاه لكن المفاجئات اتت من رئيس
جامعه القاهره حكومات خاصه للطلبه ماليه
وتعليميه في الذكرى الصفر لتنصيب الرئيس
ملكا على الجمهوريه
[تصفيق]
ظاهره مسجد المقعدين تتكرر في اوساط مؤيدي
السيسي جديد ها سيده قامت عن الكرسي ورقصت
بلا مسح ولا مزاح
[موسيقى]
اخيرا لعل مشهد هذه الفتاه يختصر ما وقعت
فيه ام الدنيا
نعم
[موسيقى]
ختاما يروي احدهم فيقول بينما كنت اسير
عائدا لبيته تحت المطر الشديد دون غطاء
وجدت رجلا عجوزا يمشي ويحمل مظله كبيره
صرت قريبا جدا منه فتنبه وسم حليب
الاقتراع ليجعل نصف مظلته فوق وما ان
وصلنا الى مدخل بنايه حتى توقف الرجل
واعطاني المظله ثم قال لي هنا بيتي ولا
احتاج ل ل مظله الان اخذها و اعطها لمن
يحتاجها بعدين الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ام
نعم
[موسيقى]
ام